it's really funny I've had the
opportunity to meet some really
visionary founders and they don't think
that they need to go through the process
of finding their why or articulating it
because they say everybody already knows
it hmm which may be true if they're
there but what happens when they leave
yeah and they just have this false
belief that because it's crystal clear
to them it's crystal clear to everyone
which it isn't and so it becomes really
important to write it down so and to
people to express it yeah what do you do
because because we see this so often in
organizations almost every organization
that has achieved any kind of success
started with the clear sense of why the
problem is that it went fuzzy the
problem is that it went away yeah and
and unless there's a like Microsoft Bill
Gates had an amazing why to help people
be more productive and Steve Ballmer
broken and thank goodness for Sachin
ardella because otherwise microcell
probably wouldn't survive you know we
saw this with Walmart you know Sam
Walton had an amazing vision about
empowering the average working and and
so so write it down but then you've
written it down and then it's somewhere
in a closet what do you do with it I
mean I say write it down yeah when I say
write it down I mean you know write it
down and share it express it mm-hmm you
know I think writing a vision statement
is important and a vision statement
should never mention your product or
your service and it should never mention
any kind of goals you know so like to be
the number one provider of X is not a
vision yeah because no it's not like
everybody feels like they can contribute
to that and it's certainly not inspiring
for anybody
[Music]
[Music]